all right John
John oh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up
from all over really uh
I was born in Philadelphia
in 53
when I was five years old
53 years old three and we moved to
Germany you know he's only five years
old you're old 70.
no I'm 70 69
you're 69 years old in one month I'll be
uh 70. wow you look incredible for 70
years 69 70.
incredible and so you born in Philly and
then went to yeah we moved to Germany uh
when I was five it's back in 59
and um it's about six years there
um because my dad worked for the
military
doing missile maintenance
Electronics
and uh my mom was German so it was it
was cool a cool time for me growing up
in Germany geez
and uh after that we moved back to the
states in uh 65.
for about a year maybe a year and a half
and uh
my dad had the same job with the
military and uh doing missile being
that's what moved to Okinawa for three
years between 66 and 69
and
I love Germany good childhood so yeah
sounds like a good childhood
it was it was great God yeah I mean you
say I mean growing up in uh in the
middle of History you know there's
history all around you in Europe
and um
going to Okinawa
geez
I loved Okinawa
and um
sorry uh
I learned a scuba dive there
historical on coral reefs just like Jack
Cousteau you know
you put your head under water man and
all these colors and all these fish
manages it was like wild
like being a dream almost
now you're mesmerized
and um you had an accident at some point
I was 15 years old 1968
and um
we lived you know we lived on the beach
basically where the Army and Marines
landed in World War II 1945 and
I discovered early on back in 66 already
that you know it's easy go out to the
reef a little low tide and you could
find all this ordinance you know from
bullets you know small caliber it's a 50
caliber rounds and uh hand grenades
rifle grenades mortar shelves 20
millimeter rounds 40 millimeter rounds I
collected all that stuff because
collector I'm German you know I'm German
leftovers in World War II not from World
War II yeah
apparently I found out years later
reading a book that uh and I don't have
photographs in the book that uh two
ammunition ships uh got struck by
kamikazes during the battle
and uh right off the reef and all this
stuff would you know scattered
so I used to collect all that stuff and
uh 68
I found the shell
it was like
you know
10 inches long maybe
three inches in diameter
I found out years later it was called a
heat shell high explosive anti-tank
and uh
I knew the thing was dangerous
we had a couple things that were
dangerous all the other stuff fuses were
all corroded out from seawater and what
but
diffuser was at the base
set the top like you would expect and uh
anyway Thanksgiving Day right after
dinner 68
I decided I was going to put my time off
from school to good use yeah sure
I'm on the right after dinner I'm
sitting on the uh on the concrete floor
of the porch
and I had Laying across my ankles the
shell
hold it my my left hand
I took hacksaw to it
and at some point
I don't know how far along I got but at
some point the thing debt needed on me
and ah shoot
this this
you can't even imagine it this
incredible Flash in a bang
the concussion man is right there it's a
big shell
everything went black
I couldn't hear
if I had not had glasses on I would have
been blind because I still have those
glasses and the one lenses all shattered
the other one is all pitted
and uh
you could tell it was high you know
intense heat on the frames
but
you know everything about black I
couldn't hear
it's it was like a light squish one
second everything's fine the next
didn't know what was happening
and I remember saying
man what a dream
and then I said
why can't I wake myself up
and years later my dad said I also he he
was in so everyone was inside no one got
hurt the dog was okay
but uh apparently he was there and he
says I I said
I'm okay now dad let me get up ah
shoot
I knew what happened
and the next thing that happened was
again it's like a dream I started seeing
a little bit of red in my eyes
it had to be the blood in my eyes I
think I don't know why you could see but
maybe someone took the glasses I don't
know what took the glasses off but
and then it was like I was staring into
the deepest red sunset you could imagine
right on the horizon I'm standing in the
middle of these tracks that go right
into the sunset
and damned if there isn't a locomotive
coming up at me for way way down the
line you can tell by the light on it
there's nothing else around it I'm in
the middle of nowhere like out in the
desert you know I've been in places like
that
and uh
it's getting closer and closer and then
I start hearing this sound again the
constant ringing has always been with me
in my you know since the explosion but I
started hearing this sound like
whoosh it's getting closer and closer
whoosh whoosh whoosh whoosh and then the
locomotive is on me
and that's when I lost it because I knew
I knew in that instant
what happened I I was already denying it
but I knew then I couldn't deny it and
it
starts screaming
it wasn't because of a pain I don't
remember any pain from the accident
it was uh It Was Fear raw fear of death
you can't imagine it
so I started screaming and thinking
screaming at my last hope if I screamed
loud enough I can make the nightmare end
and uh it didn't end
and I'm pulling and then I'm falling
through the pitch black like when you
dream you fall off a cliff
and man I mean and you're always going
to die
and I'm
I got religious
just by basically two weeks of uh of
Sunday School in Germany when I was like
six
I got kicked out of Sunday School in
Germany because uh
after two weeks two weekends because I
argued with the teacher about uh why
doesn't the Bible talk about uh the
dinosaurs or Evolution you know like
well they kicked me out
that was my that was it basically said
my religious upbringing but man when I'm
falling into the
the abyss no end to it I feel I know
it's flailing
could see hear anything I'm screaming
I'm screaming
not because of pain but
I knew I was gonna die and I I got
religious for a second I was embarrassed
because I was already an atheist
essentially anyway and uh I said God I'm
screaming god god
don't let me die please don't let me die
and uh
and I kept on screaming and screaming
nothing happened and at some point I
just I didn't give up it's just I'm
waiting for something to happen you know
I stopped screaming
and the next thing I know
I come around in the ICU
the Army hospital only five minutes down
the road from where I lived and uh all
the Vietnam wounded at that time were
going through there
next door neighbor the only person
around that had a telephone
they called the uh the hospital
and three Army Medics that worked there
they were nearby this is all secondhand
information to me from nearby they came
running to administer first aid but
I woke up in the ICU man you cannot
believe the euphoria
I mean
I mean Euphoria
all caps
just being alive
and I know I had a stupid grin on my
face I remember feeling it
and I'm still alive you know I couldn't
believe it
and then my my dad was there
when he came around and he says
you have no idea how close it was
yeah I did
I mean I had my own experience he saw
the blood and everything you know and
I'm sure he was overwhelmed it wasn't
for the Army Medics man
is my medical note say I was I was
nearly uh more abund on arrival
they had to push the blood end you know
don't let it drip and you had to push it
in
jeez
but anyway my dad's saying they're in
the ICU he says you don't have no idea
how close it I said yeah I do and he
says
wait hands look like boxing gloves with
all the gauze and what he says they had
to take a couple of fingers off your
left hand
I told him I remember my words
I can live with that
and he says the same with the right hand
all bandaged up he says well they almost
couldn't save your thumb jeez man but
look I'm thinking
yeah
man
he
did he he tells me about about my legs
they they couldn't save my legs I didn't
even know
shoot
he he talked about a second shock
I mean
God
not what I mean for as I was thinking
what now what's going to happen she's
and but you know what I never cried
about it I mean you hear me now a little
you know but never I actually
broken down and sobbed and I knew in
that instant I said oh my God you know
what have I done and that instant I
decided man
I'm gonna get past it
and about a year later
fall of 69
I got my first prosthesis it took a
little long they usually try to fit them
like within a month or so but
they're coming back from Okinawa you
know and there was there was a hassle
getting everything arranged and
but uh and I learned to walk again I uh
basically uh
holding on to a large dining room table
and hobbling around a little bit you
know build up my strength
and um
I never use crutches
not a wheelchair Walker nothing like
that it's just
for me the attitude was man
I've got to make a go of it I have to
make it look good
so
except for a small limb
aren't you pretty good
I can hike and all that but you know it
depends I feel like if I have hiking
stick I could do pretty good
so now you you're in a wheelchair but
you you do have Prosthetics that work do
you have Prosthetics you know what
happened in uh mid-may mid-may
my buddies were uh we went to the uh
Flower District the Garment District and
what and uh I can walk a block pretty
good because my strength isn't up
and um
coming back in the wheelchair uh they're
pushing me and we stopped at this
restaurant I got up to go to the
restroom I stumbled inside the
restaurant
and jeez man it's like slow motion
I fell down on the upper edge of this
lower socket caught the uh for the
restaurant
but um
I couldn't get it get back into the
wheelchair I couldn't stand up
got back to the Weingart where I'm
staying and uh
after a couple hours I had to call
paramedics and uh he did X-rays and what
at the ER you know and
Shoot actually fractured my leg bone up
here above the knee
they had to do surgery
you know big metal bar on the side of
the female you know and screws on each
end geez
I'm not even sure now if uh if the
thing's gonna fit right but
I haven't tried it on it's been it's
been over you know what
two months almost were going on
so
I don't know how long before I can put
pressure on it
if I can't walk again I'm done
I gotta be able to walk again
I'm used to being independent
I'm sorry I got emotional
it's my German Heritage you don't get
emotional about
you know what I'm saying that was your
teenage years yeah
where's your life gone since then
I managed to finish high school I have a
twin sister I finished high school
with my twin sister didn't lose any time
after that I went to college
four and a half years I double majored
chemistry and biology
there you go I went to graduate school
for about a year and a half at Johns
Hopkins University and
foreign
and uh
got a job for about a year and a half
with some company and then I got my
first government job with ATF
and I moved from Baltimore area for I've
been there for 10 years or more maybe uh
I was on my own I moved to Cincinnati
area actually Indiana
all of my dad's side of the family are
there you know so it was still I had all
family around
but ATF was a cool job for about a year
and a half
there are two branches one branch does
alcohol analysis for all the
distilleries make sure it's the proper
proof and what
the other Branch did uh forensics you
know uh
whatever it is
we analyze a lot of fireworks
explosives you know that was my my job
analyzing explosives of all things
that was cool
and I transferred about about a year and
a half later from there to uh San
Francisco they closed our lab down so
everyone trans basically everyone
transferred to San Francisco Treasure
Island out in the middle of the bay you
know and it's cool
it lasted about
nine months Maybe
and got a job with Customs U.S customs
on Terminal Island uh
there was a lab there a custom house but
I don't know what happened to it
but um I spent about
12 years there
and I got married in 82 a couple years
after moving to
LA area
and the um
you know
everything turned to crap every uh
we've been married for 38 years since uh
80 80 84.
she wanted a divorce
started last year
last couple years especially uh for me
uh
became alcoholic
and it was uh
I don't even like vodka that's why I was
drinking I used to like mixed drinks too
much hassle to mix started drinking by
the shot wash it down you know whatever
and
all to sleep to be able to sleep
because it's ringing in my ears I don't
fall asleep very easily and uh it's like
cat napping
sleep an hour wake up sleep an hour or
wake up toss and turn on it long
so I started drinking a couple shots at
bedtime
and
it just kind of progressed from there
you know you build up a tolerance like
say anything and
I started drinking a little bit just
before bedtime
just set the stage but man it just took
off over
the last year and a half especially
start drinking as soon as I wake up in
the afternoon you know afternoon usually
noon time or one o'clock and uh
my wife got sick of me uh being verbally
abusive
and uh
but man don't
you know 38 years just doesn't that
account for something you take your vows
you know For Better or For Worse
it didn't have to go to divorce right
away
what should have happened was uh
I give her a power of attorney and put
me into a darn rehab center somewhere
where you know for out however long it
takes
anything better than divorce but now
she hates me
I don't blame her
yeah
that's what's got me really depressed
it's so divorcing I never wanted to kill
myself
ever not even after the accident I mean
never crossed my mind if I'd been blind
Maybe
but um this divorcing man I
it's got me thinking about
suicide but not really not not right now
I'm not going to do it now or whatever
but
I want the option
you know worse comes the worst I'm not
gonna live on the streets jeez
I said
I can't live like this
I'm staying at the wine cart it's a
homeless shelter
man I don't have access to anything and
uh
I don't have kids got a couple of birds
the call parrots and they're like kids
you know they never grow up
and then one we had for 21 years
jeez
yeah I don't get to see them right now
maybe never again I don't know
yeah that's what's killing me right now
the depression
bad
it's a hell of a setback for a 15 year
old man
you know what
I spent a whole month in the ICU
and um
and then he put me on the ward just
before Christmas I got to go home for
for one day at Christmas time on Okinawa
and uh
but I'm on the ward with all these uh
veterans who come through Vietnam from
Vietnam and man
they became like family
you know I knew every one of them I
spent I spent three more months in the
hospital
but they were cool
I've got a photograph of me with a bunch
of them I used to say yeah I had my
camera
from home and I said hey uh get a
picture of us you know and uh
they all just like in the Vietnam photos
it shows the whole unit you know they're
all sitting there standing up you know
and someone takes a picture it's just
like that you know
everyone jumped up to get into the
picture
it was funny
but I knew some really good guys
shake that here at the Weingart
been here since uh
into January
man
I mean
I made some close friends and they're
all here you know my heart
it sounds like the
accident
with the with the bomb
with the dino was it a missile or is it
was a shell yeah
the project projectile part of a cannon
shell from a tank
before Forte you know it was a high
explosive anti-tank shell and uh it was
a projectile part and uh
man it was just laying on exposure on
the open Reef
but my dad told me years later many
years later he would never forgive he
was with me we were out Reef looking for
seashells and what you know bullets or
whatever and uh
he didn't know about the bullets he
didn't know about hardly any of my
collection
um
but he told me years later I knew we
should have left that thing alone
but now I picked it up and beholdered I
hold it home and uh but I told him man
I would have gone back by myself to get
it
I would have I know I know myself you
know but I had to have it that was a
thing I had to have that thing out do
you dwell on that one
mishap with the shell
oh I don't dwell on it you know look
back saying I just wish I hadn't done
that you know what it is whenever uh
I tell the story you know I'm sure you
can tell my wife told me many times uh I
don't tell that often not until I was in
county jail or here at the Weingart
she said I go I go into this mode
it's the truth you know like why because
I relive it and I break it out sometimes
not often but
I don't dwell on it but but
the constant ringing in my ears
I had to retire when I was uh 15 years
into the government I had to retire
because uh I got I got to the point
where I couldn't focus anymore
because I'm not sleeping you know it's
the ringing constant ringing and as soon
as I think about the ringing I go back
to the accident
but now I don't dwell on it like that in
that respect but
you start thinking about it yeah I think
yeah it's always the same thing man like
a light switch this incredible Flash and
a bang the concussion man
that wave that went through me it was
like a wave a shock wave
yeah I don't dwell on it like that
but whenever I tell the story
yeah I do go into a mode
and I remember all the detail
of what I experienced
you know it sounds like the divorce has
been as big a hit as that this is worse
it's the worst thing it's worse I don't
know
my wife won't even talk to me
not allowed to talk to her really but
it's been sort of like emergency you
know Financial emergencies or what
now
she's still full of hostility
it's over I haven't had drinks since uh
December and uh I don't care I don't
miss it I never liked vodka it was all
meant to help me sleep but it got to the
point where I wasn't doing anything but
and I saw the symptoms I saw the size I
suffered
blackouts
medical emergencies twice
problems breathing
I think it's called delirium tremens
this one of the uh um actually the most
extreme of the withdrawal symptoms and
it was always a withdrawal man
um
they fell down a couple years ago
dislocated my shoulder
two weeks after that broke it falling
over backwards uh taking a leak you know
in the bathroom at the near the bedroom
and I fell over backwards
he's
yeah they didn't have to do surgery but
my arms messed up I need a total reverse
shoulder replacement
God how is that going to work
how am I gonna put my prosthesis on uh
on once I can put them on again how do
you do that I
you need both hands
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is I'm going to be
without my wife after 38 years
uh
she's I don't know I don't know when the
divorce comes through I I don't have any
interaction with that right now
but yeah that's my big God give up my
wife after 30 years I wish he would come
around
talk a little bit
I told her to be able to have a two
years ago already a heart to heart
talk you know
about what was happening but no it
didn't happen
you said you were verbally abusive
gave her yeah and I I another occasions
where I don't even know it
there's some incidents where I don't
even know what was going on but you were
angry about what nothing
your situation or just I wish I was
the alcohol
turned me into uh
because my wife would say Jekyll and
Hyde you know that kind of thing
God it's not like it's not like me
cursing at my wife
God where's that come from I don't talk
like that
yeah that's what's really killing me
right now
you're so divorcing I
actually talked to her briefly on the
phone but man she's so
full of hostility and hatred
but I've told her you know what
I'm sorry you know uh
it should never ever happened uh it was
the alcohol but it's over it's over
and I told her I still love her and all
that
I told her I was sorry
several times
just get past it you know I don't know
if I she had enough I know
last two years especially I got out of
control I admit it
you've been through all these
events what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
I don't know you know what
the whole alcohol thing it went off for
some time
10 years maybe more but the last couple
years just ruined it's ruined to me I
tell you know what if you know there's a
problem doing some do something about it
you know do something about it
you know help yourself
I've had people tell me you know well
aren't you going to forgive your forgive
yourself yeah I don't know it's not my
way
I I did this to myself I admit it
but I wish he would just come around and
talk you know what I mean
no that's it I've said I've said what I
want to say
John thank you so much for sharing your
story I told you more than I wanted to
but if it helps someone
that'd be cool absolutely that's why I
do this
thank you very much